yeah I think that's why I don't have
enough sleep guys I have a fat dick in
my
[Music]
mouth so what are some things about
sleep that we know in this room you need
to do it or else you're going to be
unhealthy okay I know that isn't it like
a scientific somewhat of a
mystery there's something about it that
there's a lot of correlations that they
figur it out like like such as one of
them is uh I think if you stay up
um even two hours between the hours of
10 p.m. to like 6:00 a.m. if you're
awake even or something like that you
increases
uh I don't know what it was but it was
like something like testosterone yeah
like 40% like like reducing your life by
like 10 years oh [__] wow circadian
rhythm is you're supposed to be sleeping
when it's 10 p.m. your eyes should be
shut you should be knocked the [__] out
pretty much like Sunset to Sunrise type
[__] how do we fix that Bart say cool
things more dude Jesus Christ so say
Alzheimer's I don't know how to fix that
say cool things more we just got to
sleep on time that's one of parts of the
club like everyone should be
asleep please oh my God you're lowering
your life
expect DJ 40% give me the mic and it's
so delicate too the other one was like
if you need 8 hours of sleep and like
let's say you consistently get seven you
like knock out 10 years out of your life
it's like it's it's almost like it's he
wasn't serious when he said say cool
things more oh Jesus I could have been
110 yeah yeah you're for sure dying
early Nick you know any cool [__] about
sleep you're kind of one of those guys
no that's pretty much what he said like
anxiety depression testosterone all that
[__] you got youry you get fatter if you
don't sleep enough yeah right you you
just don't get to build all like for
Fitness stuff it's like you don't Muscle
Recovery Muscle Recovery everything goes
to [__] like sleep is the most important
what about when people talk about like
recovery in sports they're pretty much
being like are you sleepy enough what
about what time you go to sleep does
that matter yeah youran Rhythm you want
to match C rth so like people oh
recovering [__] ice bath whatever
it's like first sleep calories probably
drink water oh yeah eat whole foods that
don't come in like a package and are
going to expire before you do all the
[__] crazy extra [__] like Bon
patties and Trifecta get 30% off with
40% off Bart 40 the first what if what
if you're one of those people who works
like a night job right you're so [__]
they say like that's really bad what if
you're an international jet Setter and
you're always like all over the world
but you're quote unquote living the life
guess who worked graveyard for 20 years
my dad and look what happened to him
he's gone what what age was he gone
though huh but was it the sleep that
knocked probably the it's probably the
cuckoo but Stanley's 90 something he was
constantly going all over the world for
Comic Cons he died though and 90
something yeah but he's
dead Okay so check this out check this
out these are the most common myths
about sleep oh [__] we get to hear it
tell me the [__] detail you're going
to us I'm going to debunk this [__] well
you guys actually said stuff that was
pretty good I'm [__] mad about it
actually I'm not this is going to be as
good as video as I thought I thought I
was going to get to stunt and dunk on
you guys but I can't okay so myth number
one it doesn't matter what time of day
you sleep unfortunately time of day does
matter Arcadian Rhythm I told you
Arcadian Rhythm midnight Arcadian where
it guides the secretion of the essential
sleep hormone melatonin and it's
significantly influenced by natural
sunlight in our environment well if it's
not well does that mean if I'm an
international jet Setter I just have to
be linked up to the sun any kind of
light they say does that mean if we like
consistently do JK and there's no
[__] windows in this office that's
bad for us it's bad for our health and
we have an OSHA
claim but we get walks we get walks in
the middle of the day we went on a
20-minute walk hey but you're not in
employees you can't say
[__] true that's right we here at our
own will we are choosing our own hours
cuz we run our own businesses we are
collaborating they told me to be here on
time now if they were employees what
kind of employee says that to their BX I
also choose my own lunchtime and wear
whatever I want yep and we're we just
have to do what they want us to do and
sometimes I leave in the middle of
videos I'm just a guy in a room with
some cams
some lights I grab my luggage and I
leave in the middle of a whole video and
I do it and it makes me
hard dude if they make us an example
like if the state of California wants to
make us an example we're going to have
the best time going on stand because
they're they're going to be like [__] we
[__] up can't wait but can we stay
here longer like no the the case is over
get out of here I have more to talk
about we're filming this all right myth
number number two one night of sleep
deprivation will have longlasting
effects it's actually not true your
sleep is not going to be perfect every
night actually every now and again we
might struggle if we experience some
stress during the day our sleep suffers
that night for example sleep dep
deprivation or lack of sleep for at
least 24 hours can lead to short-term
adverse effects such as a lapse in
detention or an increase in resting
blood pressure but they likely resolve
with recovery sleep right so if you have
an off night don't beat yourself up uh
or do anything like don't don't think
that you're [__] over it instead try
to get back on track with your normal
sleep schedule that's good advice I like
that yeah MH uh myth number three being
able to fall asleep any time anywhere is
a good thing that used to be me it's a
myth that a good sleeper would be able
to hit the pillow and fall asleep right
away it's because sleep is actually a
process it takes a well rested healthy
person 15 to 20 minutes maybe a little
bit longer to fall asleep if you're able
to fall asleep I always fall asleep
within 5 minutes do you I do that's
really bad for your health that might
really really really really tired wait
so what if you sleep up within 15 it's
fine but when it's too quick it's not
good it's it's related to
homosexuality call me gay then I'm a
homosexual for real I knock out in like
2 minutes soon as I'm in a car it's an
islamophobic
trait stop doing that D it leads to a
conspiracy-minded brain
conspiracy you can't tell reality yeah
yeah you don't know what's reality sus
out reality who the critical thinking St
dude I'm a try my best to sleep within
20 minutes then I'll be like can't be
zesty can't be
zesty what got to stay up can't be zesty
C be zesty dude if you're able to fall
asleep immediately think about this it
may be a sign of chronically sleep
deprived State oh [__] that's probably
that's are you sleep 30 seconds you're
sleep deprived no it's because I have
sleep after you always get he is sleep
deprived you got a sead machine no I
don't you should get one maybe why you
[__] choke on your own own breath
yeah you're not you don't look fat so I
basically I'm not eating my breath and
it's fat no I'm just saying fat people
got sleep apnea when I gain some weight
bro [__] man i' be choking in my own
[__] air I just have pockets where I
just like stop breathing and then for
like 40 seconds later I'll be
like you're not a s side sleeper I try
both but like have you ever tried um
putting the tape on the mouth tape and
then see if it just forces you to
breathe through the nose or no oh and
then use a nose strip yeah that was no
strip C really that that work so you
wake up a lot of times throughout the
night I don't know if it's that I wake
up or if it's that I'm just not getting
rested or my heart's working twice as
hard to get Like Oxygen he not reming
hard enough yeah you got to REM it up
dude yeah REM it up you got to get remed
too I heard when you sleep can you rem
me real hard no I can't I can't cuz you
know about that
life is if you have a if you have a fat
dick in your mouth like you don't you
don't you don't snore okay that's
interesting I never tried it yeah I got
a guy who probably try that out it's
like a tongue
depressor yeah I think that's why I
don't have enough sleep guys I have a
fat dick in my mouth no that's why you
we got them we got them so good you got
what it takes to get
cured I sleep with the nose strip yeah
me too and then I feel way more well
rested with it on bro I can't can you
link me some no strips of course Target
you leave that on throughout the day
don't you I lowkey wear it all day
because I can breathe so much better
like that's how bad I am at mouth
breathing what if you get surgery is it
because something's inside the nose I
probably could get surgery but did you
get punched too much and then it got
swoll no I've been like that since I was
a little kid do you need to get punched
one time so you have an ex why you want
to punch me in the face no does these
days yeah look he has it on here oh yeah
he is Nick at the Rose Parade this felt
photo of you are you a black dog why do
you have that picture me in my robe dude
phones need backgrounds okay myth number
four absolutely fine um you can survive
on less than 5 hours of sleep no I can't
that's a myth some people brag about
needing only a few hours of sleep at
night not long term they that may come
from the notion in our high performing
society that well-rested people are lazy
which is a myth they're so lazy the
reality is adults need 7 hours 7 hours
to 9 hours of sleep every night that's
where you see the most Optimal Health
improved heart health longetivity brain
Heth so how do they when you're like in
the Marines or like Special Forces you
know you're like constantly sleep
deprived how almost everyone's almost
dead when they graduate oh [__] dude but
they feel better afterwards yeah
everyone's almost dead do you feel like
all the drill sergeants like they need
to read this article no they do that on
purpose to [__] your ass up cuz they're
trying to do stress aren't they yeah
they're trying to put you in a really
really like so they call they call like
diet and sleep like the great equalizer
cuz you could have some crazy D1 athlete
[__] jacked out of his mind but can
this guy sleep 3 hours a day for 4 weeks
straight and then not have enough food
and still run 10 miles then you kind of
really see what what people are made out
of that's the schedule 3 hours at night
it could be like 3 4 5 and then but then
you drag it out like everyone yeah
everyone's tough in 5 minutes but what
about 4 weeks what does that look like
you don't have enough food that's true
then then it's like oh [__] life is
rough cuz they're like oh sh you're just
falling asleep at every second you know
are you ready to to feel some pain some
of you out there especially myth 5
watching TV is a good way to relax
before bedtime oh no the blue lights wor
so people like to wind down doing that
no no no what you watching a show on a
device that emits heat like a laptop
positioned on your stomach can also
deter your ability to fall asleep I
think uh your TV and even being on your
you're not supposed to be on your phone
even within an hour but what if you turn
onto the off blue light thing no yeah
what if you got a Samsung OLED oh come
on baby how about listening to a podcast
while sleeping no no if you're listening
to Jake news it's
point I do that I listen to I listen to
podcast when i j news will put you right
to bed they put you right oh watch the
K's video [__] every time circadian
rhythm boom 5 minutes sarum cuz they
have a sarc say that again to mean
saradi sadium cuz I think they had a
study come out saying like even white
noise makers isn't good cuz technically
a part of your brain is still listening
it's like actively listening interesting
bro there's some guys that like they'll
take their phone out of their room
they'll put it in a different house
completely and the [__] so you got to
wake up and go to turn off all the
circuit breakers make sure there's no
EMF and then so you got to have two
houses to sleep good huh you got to
ground outside for like 20 minutes did
you could you guys fall asleep listening
to just music hell yeah actually music
Hypes me up well can't be like [__]
Rage Against the Machine I can't do that
but when I was when I was a teenager I
could listen to Hell RB and just I could
fall asleep to anything really but the
personal trainer guys I know who you're
talking about who like put their phone
in a [__] faay bag and like it's like
yeah like come on shut the [__] up it's
like just to be different yeah it's like
you could just get an extra hour or
something I don't know you there's ways
you you know what you know what does it
say that if you're watching MASH it's
okay that'll put anybody to sleep check
this out so watching the uh upsetting
programs like the Nightly News could
cause stress yeah that's for sure cuz
the cortisol um it'll Spike and hinder
your ability to power down however if
watching 20 to 30 minutes of a
comforting TV show like friends or
Seinfeld is a part of your sleep routine
and helps you relax wow go for it like
if it's ual istic yeah I got to stop
watching fight videos to relax and go to
sleep to too stop watching Faces of
Death hey you know what's crazy though I
do fall asleep to ji jitsu videos a lot
what they look chill yeah cuz they're
just super like that's how boring it is
yeah it can't be boring you're just like
yeah Judit is not filming what about
pimple popping videos o is that your
[__] sometimes how you fall asleep when
you're so hard though you know what I
mean when you watch those things those
are dude ingrown hair removal videos oh
bro they're the best ones they're
underrated good result do a good result
yeah cuz you just want you just want
that little that little piece of hair
that's WRA little thing wrapped around
oh see you you ever fall asleep when
Tiff's still talking to you only when
I'm really tired that's only that's only
happened
once I always fall asleep and then I
always have a Outburst before I go to
even deeper sleep really and Gio says my
Outburst is always in Chinese what how
either Chinese or Chinese gibberish like
I'll be like this or like and I knock
out that's just human gibberish that's
fun no's Chinese it's gibberish it's
Chinese my dad does that I'm just saying
my dad does that he's a white guy he's
white gibberish
then yeah see that sounds more like it I
go when he's on bodybuilding okay last
one last one last one exercising within
four hours of bedtime will disturb your
sleep that is a myth okay good I think
that's true for me hold wait it's a myth
so it's good to exercise right before
fine no it's not good it's just that
it's don't do that I can't do that I I'm
wired as soon as if I stop training at
like 9:00 I'm up bro my brain is I can't
be working out at night I do like
Jiu-Jitsu or some type of fighting sport
fire I'll be hyped for like the next 6
hours but check it out you're also
taking pre-workout no no no no exercise
releases endorphins which are mood
elevators that can help with the number
one cause of sleep difficult which is
stress so the idea is you're calming
your body down ah because it's a stress
relieving activity that makes sense okay
that's it that's all we got myth smoking
weed is sick before you pass out they
say that's bad for you too cuz I do it
go to sleep go to sleep now go to sleep
[Music]
bye
a